富山県2
帰ってきましたーー
わー
あの家ドア
実感の場合なんでそんな行為ダサくない
ですこんにちははじめ者とですというわけ
で一応うちの家族のルールとしては曲2回
打ってからだったら帰って来ていいよって
いう感じだったので時には来てにか言って
これが対策をしつつ実家に帰ることができ
ました富山県でございます今日何で帰って
きたかと言いますと実家に帰ってくるの
プレくらいだろうまず2年人ぐらいだと
思うんですよそれぐらい久々に帰ってきて
なかなか実家には父ちゃん官3人ちゃん
パンツはいるんですけども全然会えない中
結構あの家の母山に youtube やっ
ててスゴ世話になることが多くて今回その
間さを込めてうちの母さんに東京から
プレゼントを持ってきましたちょっと喜ぶ
かわかんないんですけども多分うちの母
ちゃん世代
その方にも重大なんですよ10ないと語っ
たキュッ意識するようなことは本の
プレゼント創造喜ぶと思って広げて早速
このプレゼントいつもありがとうという
ことではたしていきたいとおもいます
大根
まあまあ
あー以上ですっ
スキンとしてですね逆インターネット
スバル開いてないわけよ要は感動の再会
藤堂感動の再会に立つ会えた建機に涙も
多く入ったありがとうございます僕本当に
そのお金の管理とはまずできないんで終了
の貯金分特価空もやってもらってるんです
ね貯金できるように見えます
今
step 2ルーティ
そう言っちゃやだよああ暑い激しさは枯れ
ちゃうでしょ
ドンッペット
日本いらっしゃるんですかね
ぱわー
[音楽]
ますどうぞ
ああああああまああああああ
はいはい
お母様
うさそれです9室下げてほんと日々ですね
私のようなアホのために
あのーお金の管理ができないじゃないです
かあっちっていう本当にいつもお世話に
なってるのでちょっと
ほら感謝を込めてと言いますか
プレゼント
dj てますすいませんエコは
いや彼方ですうーんどっいってえーっ
ちょっとは入ってないですけどっ
[音楽]
ブーブー開けません
やっぱりのペンションでできなかった
スタッフでもあるん
[音楽]
完成しましたやお母様
ご覧ください
[音楽]
個
これというお店に行ってお店とかへしてお
店でも置いてある
これいっ
も増えてくだしてくれるんです以前
に増してくださいもう見てこの
らちゃんでこれ4水計安いんだけどをし
たらもうそれが使えるっていう風除熱とか
お米ってこう言ってるねー
聞こえる超パ
ハンマースキャンとか猛スピードであれを
すると脂肪が燃焼して滑りができるうーん
休眠まずった
by 吸引です暇ねーああえっ
だーっいきますねー
[音楽]
あそこにもね
a
いや座れとんねぇ
俺母さんの前になるんだろ
良いんじゃやってないからわからないと
思っているあれ機関車ちょっと
さすがにお腹達の恥ずかしいと思う
色々とか言っていますいやーだねっ
だんだんこの
内側から外に一発スっていくとちょっと
ピリッとしません
入っていうやつでございます片手間で
続けるとお母さんのくびれ手に入ります
あっ
入って使ってくださいどうもありがとう
ございますはいというわけで無事お母様に
真っ新届けることができました多分かあ
ちゃんマジでそういうエステとか店舗行っ
たことないんで黒年の師すごさとかわかっ
てないと思うんですけども実際使って
いただいて体感していただく早いかなと
思っております品としてもいいんですよ
これで僕あの教えるために1階店舗のほう
でちょっと勉強してきましたこちらご覧
くださいどうぞ
の人気ナンバーワン大
も他が他を全部できちゃう10機の搭載の
しいっ昨日なるべくいろんなことを吸収し
ている
はいお願いしまーす私も中3です13期は
ですが猫でお姉さんの日はから私はこれ
a
混ぜとえええええええええ
これお姉さんだねからおっきいですよね
そうですねいいかなやまというとがいい
ですね
[拍手]
がった方が今やからすごい混ぜてこいです
よもしケアの死後に対してアプローチして
くれまあ小高工か
でこれてとか首肩ができるはい肩こりとか
ありがたいですよ
内田がエレクトロポレーション
と言います美容セーバーを外させてくれる
予防上がるほど機能ですねなんてリスキー
な美容液パックの上から使うことが
なるほどかなりプルプル肌が作れるような
機能ですねやっぱ同時に ems って
筋肉運動もできるのでん
者が他カードだけ上げる遊べそうねそう
です引き上げができますなるほどさだに
すごいこちらですね
さんはない塗ってません提唱者式のラジオ
の if 文ライフフェスも相光を出すん
でそちらを側に交渉させてあげることで派
ありかをつくっていく
シミとか側化するか wikipedia
とか
効果的なので同時に美肌が作れるからする
美味しいですね私なんですよ
[音楽]
a
ちょっとまってまってこれがネットでよく
見る
詐欺の悪いんそんなどうなんですよ
咲レイのことですねちょっとやってみ
ましょう
ずっとに彼が木っ端グレてください
[音楽]
ベル抱き寄せると思う
井端だけやいないんだけど痩せていきます
はいしれないときゅんっ
セルライト9位いきますはいございます
[音楽]
わー
あーなるほどねはーいはぁ一歩られるな
うーん
これぞれ続けていただくとこの今の感覚か
の痛みが感覚とか[ __ ]性を突くなってくるの
で青からめちゃくちゃここは100みまし
た全然違いますねちゃんそこ地ソチで見て
いただくとここからお花をご紹介入ったさ
はないからやってきたいただきたいはい私
も先程お見せしたニキビ跡ないぞ
あよくなったんですよ
はいあーきもち行事あっはぁああ
あっぱれこれ好きですえええええあった
ねー
とレベル上げますかはい
うん実がお気に入りの美容液となパックだ
べさ
工藤さらで行プレくる肌が
いいなぁこれも毎日やるべきですね雲仙
違いますよ
気持ち
を使ったままで
カメラをカメラ面白そうああああなんか私
が知ってる気がする
凝りの下のところです
[音楽]
ブーバー
して今回ですね日頃さて他様似町久しぶり
にテーマ型に帰ってくれたのでこちらの
せる0スマートループ買ってきました本音
をちょっとぽかんとしておりましたが何
この凄さが分かると思いますぜひ使って
いただきたいと思っておりますそしてです
ね何度本日9月30日より自分でエステの
月額9800円で速い放題オールタイム
プランが抽選で500名様に当たる総額約
500ない分のプレゼントキャンペーンが
実施されております今回僕も使用した
エステの最新の機械とかが1か月間無料で
使い放題できるめちゃくちゃお得な
キャンペーンになっておりますので皆さん
是非試してくださいこちらですね10月中
に店舗に行くことが条件になっている
みたいで自分年生の高好きな
インスタグラムの方から応募できますので
みなさんぜひ概要欄からチェックしんで
くださいやーもーまじ店舗行ったいけば
こう言うなんか美容系の真っすぐとか
めっちゃ好きで超テンションわかったん
ですよねー
[音楽]
パドックあっん